dude i think we should end the episode
with the the
tweet of that dude yelling into the car
oh oh of course it's very
classic you know we had 5 000 people
uh tag us in this and then i watched it
and i realized why it's
it's very us yeah the road aren't you
get out of the truck get out of the
truck little lady
no i'm good see cause you know you lose
how do i lose
because i will beat your [ __ ] dick
into the ground all day long
the way he gets choked up on the word
long
all day long
i will beat your dick into the ground
all day he knows what he said too you
can tell his face right there he's
smiling because he's like a [ __ ] but
then he's also like doubling down
all day long follow-up is just so
good that's kind of gay isn't it
okay
i will beat your dick dude i will beat
your dick
dude pop out i like
i like to imagine that that's the
juxtaposition here that this kid doesn't
get that this dude is
actually offering
he's offering like get out of the truck
i'm gonna beat you i will [ __ ] your
dick around i will beat your [ __ ]
dick into the ground
all day long
dog i gotta hear that one more time
get out of the truck get out of the
truck little lady
no i'm good see because you know you
lose how do i lose
because i will beat your [ __ ] dick
into the ground all day long
all day long
all day long what possesses him to make
a threat like that
it's also like it's so funny he's in the
middle of the suburbs
bro bro like where is how could you
possibly get into an altercation
on this empty ass suburban this is some
road rage [ __ ] he definitely like
followed this kid down
bro that [ __ ] eating grin on his face is
so funny
i'll slap your junk around buster
i'm gonna [ __ ] put my two hands on
your dick and [ __ ]
grind it all day long
get out of this car if you want to get
sucked down on
all day long all day long
[ __ ] kind of gay isn't it
that's kind of gay isn't it i will beat
your dick
dude dude dude how about
the full clip is so funny it's so good
it's like it seems like a sketch doesn't
it seems like it's oh yeah no it doesn't
seem like real life at all
it's so good get out of the truck little
lady
come on little lady man man
i will beat your [ __ ] i've never been so
angry that i i wanted to threaten to
like
beat somebody's genitals like there's
like
a specific level of anger like you're so
pissed
you want to [ __ ] just like yeah beat
your dick into the ground and plies like
he just wants like hammer fist his nuts
like just
[ __ ] just put him on the ground and
just [ __ ] spread eagle
just hammer fist [ __ ] junk
dude just just [ __ ] a sledgehammer
right into his
junk into the cement i'll beat your dick
into the ground all day long
all day long dude i'll slap your tits
off dude
that dude got home sat down with his
family he was like
this [ __ ] guy today he's so lucky i
almost [ __ ] beat his
dick clean off
i almost [ __ ] his dick completely
off and in his house
dude there's just like glass cases of
other guys dicks that he's just
beaten literally off their body
like he sucked their penis clean off
their body
oh man like you know that's so funny
like you know they're just punching a
dick and it flies off
like you know someone gets uppercutting
a dick
yeah like when a tooth goes flying it's
the same [ __ ] like he just
he drops down on one knee and he
uppercuts the dick and he just goes
like in smash bros when you die it's a
clean break
yeah dude is smooth there this just
balls and smooth
no penis no blood no nothing nothing
it's just a clean break just no his
balls pop off too and then he looks like
a ken doll
and there's just like maybe a little bit
of scarring yeah it's like a slight scar
but that's it
it's like instant like wolverine heal
shit's [ __ ] bow
and then this dude just grabs your dick
and balls and he walks away with it he's
like
huh that's why he's so confident
laughing in his face oh yeah he's just
beating you you're
going to miss aren't you that's why he's
so confident that's why that's why he's
like
i will beat you dude
dude that's why he's so confident
because he knows
if you don't want this smoke he's like
he's like it's fine
like that he doesn't care he's like
that's fine stay in the truck man you're
better off because i'm telling you you
come out right here right now
your penis is coming off
you are going to be missing a dick like
i'm gonna beat it into the [ __ ]
ground
did you imagine that [ __ ] just you're in
a you're in a street fight
you're you're you're squared out with a
dude he drops down to one knee uppercuts
your dick and it just goes flying off
through your shorts you're like
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
like like he hits your dick and you feel
yourself get instant wood you're like
what's happening here and then the dick
is gone
you're like what how did you
no no he's like i told you
i told you you shouldn't have gotten out
of the car no dude little lady
first he uppercuts it and as you're
freaking out he just he takes exactly
five steps back and just holds his hand
out and your dick and ball is collecting
his hand like magneto just [ __ ]
yeah he sucks them down from the sky
oh yeah just they fill in his mouth and
he spits them into his hand
i told you like kirby
i told you when he slaps in the face
with it
[ __ ] the [ __ ] that's really good for
the road aren't you
get out of the truck
he's pissed just get out
come on man get out of the [ __ ] get
out of the [ __ ] truck
come on
[Laughter]
god damn bro well